bonsoir à toutes et à tous
c'est un grand moment
c'est un grand moment parce que je suis
venu avec un objet
cet objet je l'ai dans la poche
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans la poche
voilà
cet objet c'est une Porsche 911
ça fait 59 ans et demi l'année prochaine
elle passera son 60e anniversaire
alors pour certains ça peut être une
il a même beaucoup de thunes
je suis sûr qu'il fume le cigare
et peut-être gros même
et ben c'est complètement faux
ça c'est un cliché complètement faux
les gens qui possèdent cette voiture
ce sont des gens qui se sont donné les
moyens
ce sont des gens qui ont travaillé très
dur
et dont le rêve est devenu
l'aboutit enfin dans la voiture est
devenue l'aboutissement de leurs rêves
la réussite elle s'éprouve le jour
où on fait l'acquisition d'une voiture
qu'elle soit d'occasion qu'on a
configuré qu'elle soit neuve qu'on
arrive et qu'on se mette à son volant
pour vous prouver tout ça je vais vous
raconter trois histoires
je vais la laisser là parce qu'elle est
belle non
la première histoire c'est celle d'un
petit gamin
ce petit gamin il est un petit gamin qui
joue dans sa chambre il a des petites
voitures
c'est un petit peu de temps en temps un
petit peu cabossé forcément il joue avec
il provoque même de temps en temps des
accidents c'est sympa et
il s'imagine au volant d'une des
voitures il fait le bruit des moteurs
etc etc il adore la voiture en fait ce
gamin il adore la voiture il adore parce
que parce qu'il adore
parce qu'il adore
un jour il perd une dent
et là où habituellement on a une pièce
de 5 francs sous l'oreiller
la petite souris lui ramène une 911 à
l'échelle 1/43e c'est ça l'échelle 1/43
et le petit gamin il soulève l'oreiller
il est fou
il est heureux il est propriétaire de sa
première naissance
mais c'est pas fini
parce qu'un peu plus grand à Noël le
Père Noël lui offre un circuit 24 je
parle aux garçons
mais aussi aux filles
hasard ou destin
dans la boîte du circuit 24 il y a deux
Porsche 911 un truc de dingue quand même
la petite souris 24
et là il se dit mais il faut absolument
que je travaille dans l'automobile
quand la petite souris lui a apporté la
petite voiture il l'a pris il l'a posé
sur son bureau qui fait qu'il a voyait
tous les jours les voitures du circuit
24 forcément de temps en temps il est
nettoyé il faisait très attention il
était admiratif
et puis il grandit
et pour commencer dans l'automobile
c'est un milieu qui est très fermé il
commence comme stagiaire
pas tout près de chez lui il a pas de
voiture puisqu'il est stagiaire et qui
commence et donc il fait l'équivalent
d'une trentaine de kilomètres à vélo
matin et soir puisqu'il dort pas dans le
garage heureusement
il n'est pas commissionné sur les
voitures il apprend son métier pas très
facile le début est pas très facile mais
ça le motive à travailler encore plus
fort et encore plus fort
et comme il veut grandir le stage est
fini il arrive chez BMW à 21 ans
et quand il arrive chez BMW il est face
à son patron et son patron me dit je
vous remercie monsieur je ne veux pas de
votre candidature ah bon d'accord ok bon
je pensais que c'était un manque
d'expérience un seul l'était deux à 21
ans à l'époque BMW est une voiture
plutôt
très premium
face à des médecins face à des avocats
face à des notaires
il me dit ça va être compliqué vous ne
ferez pas le poids
quel challenge
je n'avais qu'une motivation
c'était de montrer à mon boss qu'il
avait tort
l'histoire a duré 22 années
et pendant ces 22 années à chaque fois
que j'étais en ville et que je croisais
911 ça me faisait un petit peu de
frisson parce que je me souvenais de la
petite souris je me souvenais des surcu
24 et je me souvenais que mon but
c'était un jour
avant d'en pouvoir en acheter une au
moins de les vendre
et au bout de 22 années j'ai une
opportunité exceptionnelle
qui est de répondre à une demande de
candidature pour ah pardon c'est le
petit gamin c'est pas moi ce sera moi
après quand je vous dirais que c'était
moi
il répond à une candidature
il passe qu'on appelle un assessement un
assessment c'est un auditeur qui est là
qui met quasiment le candidat un peu
tout nu sur plein de sujets sur plein de
choses
pour savoir s'il peut devenir
ambassadeur de la marque
alors évidemment pour être ambassadeur
de la marque faut la connaître et autant
dans certaines marques de voitures on
connaît la version actuelle celle qui
sort ou celle d'avant mais je vous
rappelle qu'elle va avoir 60 ans
et que quelqu'un qui est propriétaire
d'une voiture qu'on a 30 il vaut mieux
qu'on sache de quoi on parle quand on le
voit donc il a fallu apprendre la marque
et l'histoire de la marque
donc ce petit jeune homme qui est rentré
chez Porsche
va voir son ancien boss chez BMW ouvre
la porte et dire Monsieur le Directeur
l'instant est solennel il me dit non
j'ai dit si il me dit non je dis si
asseyez-vous
mais dit vous partez oui monsieur je
pars est-ce que je peux vous retenir
vous ne pouvez rien contraires de gosse
et donc vous l'avez compris le il
c'était moi
et quand j'apprends que j'ai la
possibilité de rentrer chez Porsche le
premier jour
où j'arrive devant le Centre Porsche et
que je vois cette façade et que
j'imagine des autos c'est forcément avec
beaucoup d'humilité beaucoup de passion
et beaucoup de motivation que j'ai passé
la porte
la deuxième histoire c'est l'histoire de
Sam
il est collégien
vous savez quand on rentre à l'école
avant parce que maintenant c'est plus le
cas chacun était placé et Sam il s'était
mis à côté de la fenêtre donc il
regardait le cours il était à côté de la
fenêtre et de temps en temps il partait
un petit peu dans ses idées et regarder
un petit peu la nature puis suivait son
cours etc puis un moment il tourne la
tête et il voit passer 7 911 tout
doucement sur la route
et là il se passe quelque chose
forcément il se passe quelque chose
à la fin de des cours il monte sur son
vélo il va au Centre Porsche en vélo il
fait du il il il
il pose le vélo le long de la
vitrine du Centre Porsche et il arrive
devant le sens et il se dit je rentre je
rentre pas je rentre je rentre pas je
rentre et rentre et devant lui une 900
c'est magique
il l'a vu sur la route et il a en face
de lui
un homme s'approche et lui dit bonjour
jeune homme comment t'appelles-tu je
m'appelle Sam monsieur je te souhaite la
bienvenue Sam
et ils font le tour de la voiture
il ouvre la porte côté conducteur Sam
s'installe au volant
le pare-brise
les pédales sont là pas très facile mais
c'est pas grave ici imagine en train de
conduire cette voiture et on sent qu'il
y a énormément d'émotions autant pour ça
que pour l'homme qu'il a reçu
au moment de partir l'homme donne sa
carte de visite à Sam Sam le médite dans
sa poche et quand il rentre dans sa
chambre il prend une punaise il met
cette punaise juste au-dessus de son
bureau avec la carte de visite et tous
les jours quand il travaille il regarde
cette carte de visite il grandit
forcément il grandit il travaille il
trouve sa voix et puis un jour
il se garde devant le Centre Porsche
la porte s'ouvre il rentre il voit
l'hôtesse d'accueil qui est là il la
salue bonjour madame bonjour monsieur je
vous souhaite la bienvenue chez Porsche
il monte la carte de visite et dit
bonjour je suis Sam
et enfin la troisième histoire c'est
l'histoire qu'un de nos clients a vécu
un client vient nous voir à 59 ans et
demi et veut se faire plaisir pour son
60e anniversaire
il a travaillé durement
il a tout fait pour que son rêve
devienne réalité et son rêve peut
devenir réalité
il arrive dans le Centre Porsche on fait
connaissance on s'installe on parle un
petit peu de voiture on fait la
configuration de la voiture on va très
loin dans des détails on va mettre des
petites surpiqûres sur le volant sur les
accoudoirs on change les jantes et
cetera on lui fait une voiture sur
mesure
il y a évidemment beaucoup d'émotions
puisqu'il est en train de construire son
rêve
et au moment où il me dit Nicolas on y
va on fait le bon de commande
est-ce que vous êtes disponible entre le
5 et le 15 octobre on était au mois de
septembre
là il me dit je peux me rendre
disponible je peux m'en disponible on
est présent au Mondial de l'automobile
Porsche instant qui est exceptionnel
où tout le monde peut venir d'ailleurs
si un jour vous allez à condition que
Porsche retourne au Mondial
on reçoit le client je suis sur le stand
je l'attends
on monte l'escalier dans un petit
endroit climatisé etc petit four truc
sympa en bas c'est la foule tout le
monde peut pas voir les voitures c'est
compliqué là il est reçu
merveilleux il est très heureux
et je lui dis maintenant on va faire le
bon de commande
alors qu'on aurait pu le faire quelques
jours auparavant
au moment de la signature du bon de
commande
il y a un petit bouton sur le bureau où
on prévient qu'une affaire a été traitée
et à ce moment-là le numéro 2 de Porsche
France ouvre la porte arrive avec un
plateau deux coupes de champagne en lui
disant bonjour monsieur bip
nous vous souhaitons la bienvenue chez
Porsche
et je l'explique aux clients je vous
présente Cyril van Belleghem numéro 2
pour chevrans qui vient vous souhaiter
la bienvenue
forcément
quand une voiture est fabriquée le
client ne savait pas que au préalable
j'avais déjà commandé la voiture dans le
système pour minimiser le temps et pour
faire en sorte que le genre de son
anniversaire sa voiture soit là mais
compte tenu de la configuration le délai
était un peu plus long et la probabilité
qu'il est la voiture le jour de son
anniversaire était faible très faible
il me demande si peu organiser une
petite cérémonie avec des amis les amis
ne savent pas qui se fait plaisir et que
c'est l'aboutissement d'un rêve et il
veut montrer à ses amis qui l'a aboutit
que son rêve aboutit et qui veut le
faire en direct avec eux donc il me
demande si on peut organiser une petite
pas de problème petit four petit Chose
etc pas d'alcool on conduit normal
les amis arrivent la veille il m'appelle
en me disant Nicolas c'est ok la voiture
est arrivée je suis désolé je suis
désolé la voiture est toujours pas
arrivé et là je sens un gros blanc dans
la conversation forcément c'est un rêve
il a son anniversaire le lendemain et il
a ramassé la voiture
ne vous inquiétez pas je dis j'ai deux
solutions la première en décale votre
anniversaire il me dit pas possible je
suis une telle date je peux pas décaler
la logique
la deuxième solution que je lui propose
c'est pour l'instant de ne rien dire à
ses amis puisque ses amis sont pas au
courant que c'est une surprise donc on
va pas dévoiler une surprise et je lui
dis je vais mettre sous la housse
puisque les voitures sont où c'est quand
les clients viennent évidemment je vais
mettre cela aussi une voiture qui va
avoir la même forme que la vôtre
ce sera pas la vôtre puisqu'elle est pas
là
et puis
pour vous faire patienter le temps que
votre voiture arrive on fera une mise en
main vous partirez avec la voiture qu'on
aura découvert et lorsque la votre
arrivée on fera l'échange avec votre
voiture là forcément il est très heureux
parce que du coup il va pouvoir faire
plaisir à ses amis il évidemment un peu
déçu un peu triste que ce soit pas la
sienne les amis arrivent
on avait caché la voiture on a mis le
truc machin prépare le scénario tout va
bien qu'est-ce que vous faites là
monsieur je suis là
et
on commence la mise en main avec un de
mes collègues je prends la hausse un d'à
côté un de l'autre et on dévoile la
voiture devant ses amis forcément elle a
ému forcément très émue de voir une
voiture qui n'est pas la sienne mais une
voiture qui ressemble à la sienne
et là j'y prends la parole et dit ses
amis regardez voilà ça fait 60 ans chez
travailler pendant plus de 40 ans j'ai
économisé j'ai fait tout ce qu'il
fallait mais ma motivation c'était
d'arriver à assouvir mon rêve et mon
rêve il est là et je voulais le partager
avec vous c'est quelque chose de très
beau surtout quand ce sont des amis
et je lui dis monsieur X on va aller
faire un tour au Centre Porsche
classique puisqu'on a deux centres
Porsche à Rouen un moderne un classique
et je lis là-bas il y a des vieilles
voitures encore une fois 60 ans donc il
y a des voitures qui ont quasiment 60
ans exposés et ça mérite le coup d'oeil
pour les gens qui aiment ça mérite du
coup d'œil on emmène tout le petit monde
on fait la visite du classique
sauf que la voiture est arrivée le matin
et pour préparer une voiture avant la
mise en main il faut entre 24 et 48
heures
pour que la voiture soit préparée autant
d'un point de vue technique esthétique
et là sachant que la voiture est arrivée
le matin mon premier réflexe a été le
voir mes collègues en disant mes
collègues les gars challenge
entre 16h et 17h on fait la mise en main
d'une voiture vous êtes au courant que
c'est pas celle du client oui on est au
courant sauf qu'elle vient d'arriver
donc challenge pour 16h 17h faites le
maximum pour que la voiture soit sous la
hausse calé au même endroit au carreau
près
on termine la visite du centre classique
on arrive dans le showroom les gens très
contents etc super vous avez magnifique
c'est un coffrage à jouer génial et j'ai
dit écoutez maintenant on va faire la
mise en main de la voiture mais c'est
vous qui allez l'aide où c'est beldi
c'est pas la peine on l'a déjà fait mais
je dis pour partir c'est plus facile de
retirer la housse puis autant que ce
soit vous qui l'a retiriez ça va être
plus sympathique quand même
et là il prend il se met à l'avant de la
voiture ses amis sont derrière forcément
ils se mêlent avant de la voiture il
prend la hausse il commence à retirer
comme ça et il aperçoit le pare-choc
et il met à genoux à terre il met à
genoux à terre comme ça et il se met à
pleurer
la voiture qu'on avait mis elle était
noire elle est celle qu'il avait
commandé elle était blanche et sous la
housse il y avait une voiture était
blanche et c'était sa voiture
donc forcément c'est un moment
extraordinaire pour lui
je suis allé chercher des collègues je
lui dis que c'était un travail parce que
la réussite elle est pas forcément
personnelle elle est aussi collective on
est allé chercher les collègues on a
montré qu'il y avait six collègues qui
avaient travaillé sur la voiture pour
qu'elle soit là aujourd'hui et on a fait
de ce moment un moment extraordinaire
pour le client
ça fait 34 ans je travaille dans
l'automobile des histoires je pouvais en
raconter beaucoup je trouvais que ces
trois histoires étaient importantes
la première parce qu'elles ont tout été
vécues
et c'est donc la vérité
la deuxième c'est pas ce qu'elle vous
montre que visualiser sa réussite c'est
comme un certain nombre d'entre nous
tout la date tout à l'heure nous l'avons
dit c'est réalisé un rêve et se donner
un but et qu'on aille et que ce soit
l'aboutissement d'un rêve personnel
alors autant que vous êtes ce soir
même si vous n'en avez pas les moyens
mais si vous en avez l'envie moi je vous
ouvre les portes du Centre Porsche
moderne je vous ouvre les portes du
Centre Porsche classique
tant qu'il y a de la lumière vous êtes
les bienvenus